alors désinscrit l'article 32 madame
Thomas
merci madame la Présidente
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président
Madame la rapporteur chers collègues au
moment d'aborder l'examen du chapitre 5
relatif au renforcement de la sécurité
des systèmes d'information je tenais à
rappeler la démarche du groupe
socialiste et apparenté dire d'abord que
nous travaillons sur les articles à
venir 32 à 36 sous le regard et la
vigilance du Conseil constitutionnel
rappelait que lors des débats en
commission des lois l'un de mes
amendements portés au nom du groupe PS
amendement essentiel pour se voler de la
LPM a été adoptée celui-ci visait à
l'exigence d'assermentation des agents
de l'autorité nationale en matière de
sécurité et de défense des systèmes
d'information que le texte initial
supprimé ces agents recueillent des
données auprès des acteurs numériques
leur assermentation est nécessaire pour
exercer cette fonction sensible
cette garantie est désormais maintenue
dans le texte de loi que nous examinons
et nous nous en félicitons madame la
rapporteur
en tant que législateur nous tenons à
affirmer le niveau d'exigence et de
garantie auquel nous sommes
particulièrement attachés il s'agit de
renforcer les pouvoirs de cette autorité
de contrôle à travers les articles à
venir ce qui est une bonne chose mais
nous tenons à affirmer que ce
renforcement des pouvoirs ne peut être
mis en oeuvre sans apporter un cadre
équilibré afin de fixer les limites que
devra respecter l'administration dans le
plus strict respect des droits et des
libertés dans un contexte d'explosion
des attaques cybers pour anticiper et
contrer ses attaques nous sommes
favorables à l'élargissement des
pouvoirs de l'annecy mais nous tenons
aussi à travers l'examen des articles à
poursuivre le travail engagé en
commission des lois fixez des garanties
pour que l'administration agisse dans un
cadre strict et des limitée et que notre
loi s'inscrive dans le respect de la
Constitution je vous remercie merci
madame Thomas madame le Hainan
merci madame la présidente Madame la
rapporteur monsieur le ministre le
groupe horizon s'exprime en faveur de
cet article l'article 32 donc qui permet
à Annecy en cas de menace susceptibles
de porter atteinte à la sécurité
nationale de prescrire plusieurs menaces
prescrire pardon plusieurs menaces
graduelles affectons les noms de domaine
en particulier leur blocage ou leur
suspension ainsi que leur redirection
vers un serveur sécurisé ou neutre
contrôlé par l'ansy nous n'avions pas
émis de réserves en commission sur cet
article mais nous avions souhaité des
précisions du périmètre d'application
aussi nous avions présenté un amendement
visant à exclure les bureaux
d'enregistrement donc à vocation plus
commerciale de cet article au bénéfice
exclusif des offices d'enregistrement
qui ont déjà les moyens de mettre en
oeuvre les dispositions prévues
amendement que nous avons retiré après
les explications de Madame la rapporteur
nous nous réjouissons des modifications
apportées en commission tels que la
prise en compte par l'ansy de la nature
du titulaire ainsi que de ses
contraintes opérationnelles
l'abaissement du délai de conservation
des données à 5 ans au lieu de 10 par
également une bonne chose de même que le
délai de 2 jours ouvrés pour l'exécution
par les opérateurs des mesures prises
par l'ansy enfin il nous a paru
important que le décret d'application du
présent article soit pris après avis de
la CNIL pour toutes ces raisons le
groupe horizon votera en faveur de cet
article ainsi rédigé et pour lequel nous
avons jugé nous n'avons pas jugé utile
de redéposer d'amendements en séance je
vous remercie merci madame la députée
monsieur bernalicis
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente
[Musique]
bon moi je suis encore tout à fait
extrêmement sceptique sur le la portée
de cet article 32 et des nouvelles
progressives qui sont données à Annecy
on a eu un petit débat en commission
sans pour avoir autant avoir un
éclairage complet sur la nécessité de
cet article par rapport à d'autres
dispositifs qui existent déjà dans le
droit et ce qui est fait à l'heure
actuelle notamment sur le délai où on
est on est on est proposé 72 heures en
disant bah attendez un référé liberté
c'est 48 heures pour contester la mesure
72 ça doit être le minimum finalement
vous êtes 48 heures et que j'ouvre et
bon bah du coup je me suis dit qu'il va
l'aimer se faire attaquer le vendredi
pour avoir une journée de plus pour
pouvoir éventuellement faire valoir ses
droits devant le tribunal administratif
je vois que ça fait sourire le
ministrement sauf qu'on en est là quoi
sur les garanties juridiques quoi devoir
faire des boutades pour attirer
l'attention d'un sujet de liberté
fondamentale et de droit et puis il y a
un élément plus général c'est à dire que
depuis la commission bon j'ai lu un
certain nombre d'articles sur le
fonctionnement de l'ansy actuel
la distance de plateforme régionale pour
signaler les problématiques avec une
sous-traitance une concurrence des
embrouilles à l'intérieur de l'ancie et
des régions partenaires et le fait qu'en
fait en réalité dans bien des cas ces
plateformes pour les TPE PME en fait
servent à renvoyer vers d'autres
personnes privées chargées de faire de
la sécurité privée que l'insigne ne fait
que pas se plat et donc si c'est pour
donner des progressifs plus larges à une
institution une institution une agence
pardon gouvernementale qui ne fait que
pas ce poids vers des organismes privés
je sais pas il manque deux trois
garanties pour que pour que je me dise
que effectivement on va respecter l'État
de droit et les libertés fondamentales y
compris des détenteurs de du RL par
exemple et de noms de domaine donc
voilà moi je à ce stade je ne suis pas
convaincu par la pertinence de cet
article et j'aimerais qu'on puisse avoir
des réponses de la part du gouvernement
merci monsieur le député nous allons
aborder maintenant les amendements à
l'article 1269 monsieur Yordan OV
merci madame la Présidente
dans sa rédaction actuelle les mesures
confiées à l'ancien en matière de
filtrage et noms de domaine peuvent être
utilisés dans des cas de menaces
susceptibles de porter atteinte à la
sécurité nationale cette notion est très
évasive les prérogatives de cette agence
du gouvernement sont donc très étendues
et l'impact sur la liberté d'accéder au
service de communication les deux temps
la moins des précautions serait de
préciser les finalités pour lesquelles
elles peuvent être employées pensons
qu'il faut circonscrire le champ
d'application de l'article 32 en
limitant son usage au seul cas où la
menace est susceptible de porter
atteinte aux intérêts fondamentaux de la
nation je propose de sécuriser cette
rédaction en renvoyant à l'article 410-
du code pénal qui visent uniquement
l'indépendance de la France l'intégrité
de son territoire sa sécurité la forme
républicaine de ses institution les
moyens de sa défense et de sa diplomatie
la sauvegarde de sa population en France
et à l'étranger l'équilibre de son
milieu naturel son environnement et les
éléments essentiels de son potentiels
scientifiques et économiques et de son
patrimoine culturel c'est une rédaction
un peu plus précise et en tout cas
différents de ce que j'avais proposé en
commission puisqu'on m'avait dit que
renvoyé au code de la sécurité
intérieure n'était pas pertinent mais on
avait quand même tout le monde il y
avait un consensus sur le fait qu'il
fallait lister des cas précis parce que
la notion de sécurité nationale est trop
vague je vous remercie si Monsieur le
Député madame la rapporteur avis de la
commission
il a évoqué ce sujet en commission et je
comprends tout à fait le sens mais il
est toujours notre souci est toujours
d'être
suffisamment large tout en étant un peu
précis c'est un peu pour permettre aussi
à notre à nos lois de vivre dans le
temps et de faire face à plus de
situations compliquées possible donc
votre rédaction ne permet pas
nécessairement de couvrir des cibles
privilégiées des cyber attaquants qui
sont aujourd'hui quand même aussi les
hôpitaux les collectivités
territoriales territoriales donc nous
devons aussi penser à ces situations là
et légistiquement il y a un mélange de
genre qui est peut-être pas bienvenue et
qui pourrait ouvrir une voix un mauvais
amalgame parce que il faut quand même
souligner que lundi est un service de
cyberdéfense et des cybersécurités et ne
donc pas un service de renseignement et
nous faisons très trop souvent on l'a
fait en commission aussi
elle a donc pas vocation à suivre les
personnes mais
suivre surtout et identifier les
victimes et de faire face à ces
situations quand même compliquées donc
dans un souci d'harmonisation des
rédactions entre les articles la
formulation actuelle qui porte atteinte
ou qui fait référence au ménage
susceptibles de porter atteinte à la
sécurité nationale qu'on vient davantage
donc à vie défavorable merci Madame la
rapporteur monsieur le ministre avis du
gouvernement
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés d'abord
permettez-moi de saluer la qualité du
travail qui a été réalisé même la
rapporteur pendant les travaux en
commission et qui ont permis d'affiner
considérablement l'écriture de cet
article ainsi que des suivants je pense
notamment au sujet soulevé par Monsieur
Bernal ici à l'instant sur les délais
opérationnels de mise en oeuvre je pense
à la durée de conservation des données
non identifiantes qui est passé de 10
ans à 5 ans ou encore à l'avis de la
CNIL qui est préalable à la prise du
décret d'application de cet article donc
merci pour ce travail qui a été réalisé
et s'agissant de cet amendement pour
compléter les propos de Madame la
rapporteur d'abord redire comme elle l'a
fait qu'effectivement la notion
d'intérêt fondamentaux de la nation est
une notion du code pénal or le Lancy n'a
pas de capacité ou de vocation d'enquête
dans ce ce domaine là et donc la reprise
de ce de ce terme est et l'évocation de
ce code pourrait introduire une
confusion et par ailleurs sur les
intérêts fondamentaux de la nation on
couvre un spectre plus large que celui
de la sécurité nationale puisque il y a
englobe y compris des sujets comme la
sauvegarde du patrimoine culturel ce qui
élargirait très considérablement la
portée de cet article enfin simplement
pour pour rassurer la représentation
nationale le concept même de sécurité
nationale a été sanctionné par le
Conseil constitutionnel comme étant
comme étant suffisamment précis à
l'occasion de l'examen par le Conseil
constitutionnel d'une question
prioritaire de constitutionnalité qui
avait été déposée sur la loi 5G il nous
paraît donc qu'il est entouré de toute
la précision nécessaire et c'est la
raison pour laquelle la vie est
défavorable sur cet amendement merci je
vais mettre au voile amendement 1269 qui
a reçu un avis défavorable de la
commission et du gouvernement qui est
pour
qui est contre il n'est pas adopté
madame Ménard le 1121
défendu madame la rapporteur avis de la
commission
défavorable merci monsieur le ministre
je vais mettre voix cet amendement qui a
reçu un avis défavorable de la
commission et du gouvernement qui est
pour qui est contre il n'est pas adopté
monsieur bellamythy le 1665 merci madame
la Présidente Monsieur le Ministre
madame a rapporteur Messieurs les
Présidents de la commission le président
rendement visa élargir le champ
d'application de l'article 32 ou
fournisseur de résolution de nom de
domaine défini à l'article 33 du présent
projet de loi dans leur globalité sans
limiter sa portée aux seules hébergeurs
et fournisseurs d'accès Internet en
effet en l'état actuel de la rédaction
les personnes qui fournissent des
navigateurs Internet ne sont pas inclus
dans le dispositif et il en est de même
pour les systèmes d'exploitation
mentionnés à l'article 32 du Code des
postes et communications électronique
présentement permettrait par conséquent
d'inclure dans le champ de l'article les
navigateurs et systèmes d'exploitation
qui font de la résolution de noms de
domaine soit inscrit dans un objectif de
clarification rédactionnel de cohérence
vis-à-vis du droit positif et dans la
volonté d'inclure tous les acteurs
impliqués dans la sécurisation du
système DNS afin d'aboutir à une
meilleure effectivité du dispositif et
je précise que notre collègue Eric
Bothorel avait évidemment travaillé cet
amendement avec les services de l'annecy
et j'aurais en profiter pour le
féliciter et l'excuser son absence pour
pour ce travail je vous remercie merci
Madame la rapporteur
c'est alors merci cher collègue cette
disposition complète assez utilement
article l'article 32 et assura une
portée plus large des mesures de blocage
prévues donc je suis favorable merci
Monsieur ministre
merci Madame la présente bienvenue sur
les députés effectivement une
clarification très utile pour renforcer
le dispositif à vie favorable du
Gouvernement merci je vais mettre au
bois cet amendement
bon alors là on élargit
sans qu'on nous est rassuré pleinement
sur les garanties du dispositif et de ce
qui va s'en suivre donc là par
précaution moi je vous dis non on va
commencer à essayer vos vos vos
exceptions par rapport aux droits
communs prérogatives exorbitantes pour
l'annecy sur un périmètre un peu plus
secure parce que je vous entendais tout
à l'heure madame la rapporteur nous
expliquer que c'est pour défendre nos
hôpitaux pour défendre six etc donc j'en
déduis qu'aujourd'hui on les défend pas
et qu'on a aucun dispositif dans le
droit qu'on fait rien qu'on regarde on
regarde le passé qu'on se fait attaquer
comme ça et que l'ancien n'aurait aucune
problématique et y compris nos services
de de renseignements parce qu'on avait
on nous avait dit oui mais lundi n'est
pas un service de renseignement on a
souri on nous a oui oui effectivement
c'est vrai c'est juste enfin j'espère
qu'il travaille avec eux parce que quand
même les attaques les cyberattaques
souvent nos services d'enseignement sont
aussi au courant parfois et certains
canaux j'espère qu'ils communiquent
entre eux mais il y a quand même un
enjeu là-dessus à se dire mais bon sang
ok le Conseil constitutionnel a dit oui
ça va sécurité nationale ça va c'est
suffisamment précis pour être pour être
large
le Conseil constitutionnel il fait pas
un contrôle un maxima plus depuis
longtemps il est plutôt même favorable à
ce que le gouvernement est un maximum de
progressif de mains libres tant qu'il y
a pas trop d'incompétence négatives mais
enfin nous on est quand même en droit de
regarder très près ce à quoi vont servir
les mesures administratives à
tentatoires aux libertés parce que c'est
ça dont on est en train de parler avec
cet article
dans quelle portée êtes-vous servir en
dépit que ce soit constitutionnel en
l'état actuel de la 5e République voilà
j'ai jusqu'à c'est pas juste un argument
d'autorité regardez le Conseil consiste
à déjà dit dans une
QPC que c'était bon et circulé il y a
rien à voir et on va étendre le
périmètre là par cet amendement à
d'autres dispositifs donc voilà moi
l'état je ne voterai pas cet armement
parce que encore une fois y compris dans
l'étude d'impact on n'a pas suffisamment
d'éléments sur qu'est-ce que aujourd'hui
on ne pourrait pas faire et qui que
demain nous permettra de faire ce deep
de dispositif élargi merci Monsieur la
tombe merci madame le Président
effectivement commission des lois nous
avions eu cette discussion sur les
moteurs de recherche qui sont pas inclus
dans cet amendement c'est peut-être le
seul bém pour le groupe démocrate on
mettra sur sur l'amendement parce que il
faut effectivement l'élargir et cet
amendement est bienvenu parce que on
sait très bien que les navigateurs
évoluent technologiquement de façon très
importante depuis quelques semaines
quelques mois que l'intelligence
artificielle qui va être intégré dans
les navigateurs va permettre à des
attaquants de pouvoir s'en saisir et
mettre des failles et donc on a
absolument besoin de donner à l'ancien
la capacité d'élargir et c'est vraiment
le fait et pour répondre à notre
collègue burnisme enfin on l'a dit on
l'a dit en
commission des lois le fait d'avoir
modifié le début de l'article 32 nous va
bien et pour répondre à votre question
le fait que ça soit une QPC et sur la
loi 5G securise le terme juridique que
nous avons adopté en commission des lois
c'est pour ça que sur cette partie là
nous n'avons plus de réserve sur le
début de l'article 32 et que nous
soutiendrons aussi cet amendement qui
élargit parce qu'il faut absolument
donner à l'ancy les moyens de prévenir
des menaces qui vont arriver dans les
semaines à venir parce que les
évolutions techn ologiques notamment des
navigateurs vont permettre dans le cadre
notamment de la partie Jo que nous
allons avoir des attaques et nous avons
absolument besoin de donner à Annecy en
élargissant par cet amendement c'est
peut-être un des amendements
d'élargissement que nous soutiendrons
alors que nous étions plutôt en
restriction au moment de la commission
des lois sur cet article 32 mais la
modification du début de la phrase avec
la référence à ce que le Conseil
constitutionnel a validé occupé c'est
nous permet d'être rassuré avis que nous
soutiendrons du côté modem
merci je vais mettre aux voix cet
amendement 1665 et reçu un avis
favorable de la commission et du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre il est adopté les
amendements identiques le 1714 monsieur
bernalissy sous monsieur Saintoul merci
madame la Présidente là on revient sur
le délai juste un petit commentaire sur
ce qu'on vient de faire d'élargir juste
avant c'est quand même assez
extraordinaire que que finalement le
gouvernement de lui-même dans son projet
de loi initiale n'est pas été capable en
lien avec ses propres services de l'ency
de dire ah oui il faut les moteurs de
recherche dedans donc déjà rien que ça
ça devrait d'alerter sur le fait qu'il y
avait peut-être un petit débat en
interne sur le fait que c'était
peut-être touchy ou pas nécessaire tout
simplement bon mais bon mettons ça de
côté maintenant c'est en combien de
temps on peut faire valoir ses droits
quand l'administration
n'est pas dans son bon droit justement
où s'est trompé ou juste les gens
veulent faire par principe avoir la
possibilité de faire valoir leurs droits
et le circuit qui va avec on était à 24
heures au départ alors je me suis dit
bah en fait c'est pas compliqué ils ont
voulu aligner sur le délai qui existait
déjà dans la loi introduit par les
macronistes même quand il y a des fake
news sur internet en demandant aux
plateformes en 24 heures et puis après
je me suis dit bah si c'est des intérêts
de la nation en fait il y a déjà une
autre dispositif qu'on a mis dans lutte
contre le terrorisme etc il faut retirer
le contenu en une heure en une heure bon
j'étais contre j'ai essayé de
conséquences hit mais enfin c'est ce que
vous avez proposé donc je me suis dit
bah pourquoi ils font pas une heure
c'est quand même la sécurité nationale
quoi c'est quand même un truc énorme et
les hôpitaux et tout ça et puis
finalement
vous-même vous mettez plus 24 vous
passez à 48 heures ouvrées alors que du
coup s'il y avait quelque chose sur
lequel s'aligner de logique de la limite
cohérent c'est à minimal et 72 heures
pour pouvoir faire ce recours devant le
tribunal administratif donc voilà
j'aimerais bien comprendre le
raisonnement qui vous a amené à faire 24
dès le départ pourquoi pas une heure et
arriver à 48 ouvrés est-ce que c'est moi
je sais pas vous avez fait pile ou face
est-ce que c'est vous avez pris deux
extrêmes on prend le couple la poire en
deux auprès pile au milieu non mais je
sais que des fois ça se fait comme ça
sur un coin de table on peut pas être
complètement naïf sur comment se
fabrique la norme dans notre pays aussi
c'est comme ça qu'on a fait les 3% de
Maastricht donc pourquoi pas et donc en
réalité j'aimerais qu'on puisse avoir
des garanties supplémentaires avec ces
72 heures merci monsieur le député
monsieur Saintoul il est défendu 1727
avis de la commission madame leur
rapporteur sur ces deux amendements
identiques
ma chère collègues ce qu'on essaie quand
même de trouver c'est à chaque fois un
équilibre et je veux dire on a fait
quand même des auditions sur ce texte on
a écouté entre autres les opérateurs et
on a écouté aussi nos structures
administratives ainsi et tout le monde
et donc on a essayé de mettre le curseur
là où il paraissait le plus pertinent
justement pour essayer de faire face à
une situation compliquée mais ne pas
alourdir aussi des charges aux
opérateurs d'où le délai finalement
qu'on a adopté avec 48 heures
ouvrés donc avis défavorable merci
monsieur le ministre
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
bernatis le gouvernement n'a pas la
science infuse et c'est la raison pour
laquelle ces textes s'enrichissent
dans la discussion parlementaire à
l'Assemblée nationale comme au Sénat
alors je veux simplement rectifier l'un
des éléments que vous avez cité au
départ dans le texte le délai qui a été
prévu était de 48 heures effectivement
c'est un délai qui est plus long que les
24 heures qui sont prévus pour le
retrait des contenus terroristes et des
contenus pédopornographiques
que les hébergeurs doivent opérer sur
injonction des des forces de l'ordre le
choix qui a été fait
a été retenu pour des raisons
opérationnelles et là encore la
Commission en entendant les les
problèmes opérationnels que ce délai de
48 heures pourrait provoquer a décidé de
de l'assouplir en tenant compte des
jours ouvrés c'est le compromis de la
Commission et le gouvernement se range
derrière ce compromis
merci je vais mettre au bois ces deux
amants oui monsieur bernalicis
merci madame la Présidente alors oui le
gouvernement comme beaucoup de monde n'a
pas la science infuse mais il a des
services à sa disposition qui
normalement dont c'est le travail de
dans le cadre de l'étude d'impact
notamment de anticiper de voir qu'est-ce
qu'on peut pas faire aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait faire demain
avec le texte qui est là pour moi c'est
toujours pas clair dans l'étude d'impact
sur cet article 32 par rapport à l'état
actuel du droit aujourd'hui ce qu'on va
ce qu'on va changer et améliorer en la
matière et donc là vous dites vous-même
que vous vous êtes aligné sur un délai
qui est un si je suis le raisonnement
aussi de Madame la rapporteur des
auditions un équilibre entre les
opérateurs qui ont dure quand même des
délais aussi courts faut qu'on mette des
moyens derrière des gens bon ok c'est la
sécurité nationale mais enfin bon vous
êtes pénible et puis des gens comme nous
qui disons bah oui mais attendez il faut
peut-être avoir les délais de recours
pour dire qu'on soit encore un peu dans
un état de droit
j'aimerais comprendre par de la
l'équilibre ce sur quoi je vous
interroge c'est sur la logique quelle
est la logique qui est poursuivie si la
logique c'est de dire c'est du contenu
extrêmement problématique un hôpital qui
est en train de se faire attaquer etc je
suis même prêt moi à admettre que 72
heures c'est trop long que 48 heures
ouvrées c'est trop long
et si c'est pas ça si c'est pas si
extrêmement important que ça écologique
ça se passe déjà bien avec l'ancien des
services et que c'est surtout une
question de moyens humains qu'on met
derrière parce qu'on peut faire bien
plus vite que 72 heures de part et
d'autre les opérateurs et chez Nancy
juste en mettant des gens en plus bon
bah à ce moment-là laissons-nous
effectivement un délai qui correspond à
quelque chose de logique quand à faire
valoir ses droits dans le cadre d'un
état droit devant un tribunal
administratif dans la procédure de
référé voilà moi je poursuis une logique
et j'argumente j'aimerais qu'on fasse on
puisse être sur la même longueur d'onde
merci Madame le hennant
si je peux peut-être apporter des
éléments qui rassurerait
[Musique]
notre collègue c'est que si c'est la
logique que vous recherchez il y en a
une qui est simple c'est que quand il y
a deux parties il y a l'opérateur qui
doit intervenir pour je dirais faire son
travail en l'occurrence l'annecy et
qu'en parallèle on demande à la personne
ou à l'organisation l'entreprise qui est
la cible de réagir la logique est de
pouvoir finalement trouver un temps
acceptable pour les deux parties on en
avait parlé en commission l'idéal serait
effectivement qu'en une heure 26 puce
intervenir elle ne peut pas parce qu'il
y a il y a
la l'organisation qui doit réagir et
donc c'est un la logique c'est assez
simple c'est finalement trouver un temps
acceptable pour l'opérateur ainsi en
l'occurrence et puis la structure qui
devra réagir dans un temps qui
matériellement et acceptable
merci je vais mettre voici deux
amendements identiques qui ont reçu un
avis défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui compte
ne sont pas adoptés le 1274 monsieur
ordanov
merci Madame la Président je pense que
la question de la rapidité ne peut pas
être l'unique préoccupation surtout sur
ces sujets quand même un peu important
de des libertés fondamentales sans
revenir sur la nécessité de renforcer
les capacités d'intervention de l'ancien
il faut un arsenal juridique qui
respecte les droits et libertés nous
proposons avec cette amendement de
renforcer les droits des personnes
visées par les injonctions prises par
l'annecy en prévoyant qu'elle puisse
être en mesure de présenter leurs
observations et le cas échéant de
régulariser leur situation
l'objectif étant de d'éviter des
situations arbitraires ou des problèmes
des fois qui sont pas forcément
volontaires et qu'on puisse couper des
accès à l'information sans raison
valable merci
merci madame la Présidente chers
collègues ce dialogue est déjà prévu
dans l'article la ligne à deux du texte
dispose que lundi s'adresse d'abord au
titulaire du nom de domaine et c'est
seulement en cas de carence de ces
derniers qu'elle saisit les fournisseurs
d'accès à Internet ou les hébergeurs et
d'ailleurs on Commission on a adopté un
amendement qui prévoit que l'ancien
compte de la nature du titulaire du nom
de domaine ainsi que des ces contraintes
opérationnelles et par ailleurs et d'un
point de vue légistique votre amendement
complète la ligne à 10 c'est alinéa
concerne à la fois les titulaires ayant
enregistré leur nom de domaine de bonne
foi avec lesquels un dialogue est déjà
bien prévu comme je l'ai précisé mais
c'était alinéa concerne aussi les cyba
attaquants ayant enregistré de mauvaise
foi un nom de domaine pour orchestrer
une attaque dans un tel cas de figure il
me paraît pas pertinent de demander à
l'attaquant de présenter ses
observations défavorables
il me soumise
mais ma vie monsieur Saint-Ouen
madame la Présidente pour poursuivre
notre échange sur cette histoire de
délai je suis quand même très curieux je
suis pas de la commission des lois je
suis plutôt novice sur ces sujets mais
quand j'entends dire que on a un délai
de 24 heures s'agissant de contenu
terroristes ou pédopornographique mais
que on choisit 48 heures quand il est
question de sécurité nationale je vois
pas bien la cohérence quand j'entends
notre collègue nous expliquer que
l'idéal ce serait une heure mais que on
ne peut pas j'ai envie de vous dire
bêtement pourquoi en matière de sécurité
nationale l'idéal et le standard ne
coïncide pas ce sont des objectifs qui
me paraissent
normaux c'est peut-être un tropisme de
commissaire de la défense quand on nous
parle sécurité nationale on est le petit
doigt sur la couture du pantalon j'en
sais rien mais ça me paraît quand même
très curieux qu'on puisse arriver avec
des inventures et nous dire bon l'idéal
en matière de sécurité nationale ce
serait une réactivité d'une heure mais
finalement on va passer à 48 heures j'ai
pas je ne comprends pas la logique
merci je vais mettre voix cet amendement
qui a reçu un avis défavorable de la
commission et du gouvernement qui est
pour
qui contre il n'est pas adopté le 171
madame Thomas
la présidente cet amendement des députés
socialistes en tant conditionné
l'exécution des mesures prévues par
l'article 32 de la LPM à la vie confort
de la recette en tant qu'autorité
administrative indépendante la recette
est un gage de respect de nos droits et
de nos libertés fondamentales dans
l'application de telle mesure comme
évoqué tout à l'heure le groupe
socialiste ne s'oppose pas au
disposition disposition etant les
pouvoirs de l'annecy mais nous
souhaitons l'alimenter par des garanties
dans le respect de notre État de droit
nous avons le pouvoir de formuler des
injonctions aux opérateurs afin de
sécuriser le contrôle et l'exploitation
des systèmes d'information nous
considérons que seul larcep est en
mesure de fournir des avis conformes
pour préserver nos libertés nos
garanties posées en ce sens sont utiles
pour contraindre l'administration au
respect des droits et des libertés
merci Madame la rapporteur
merci madame la Présidente donc votre
amendement prévoit de conditionner la
mise en place de toutes mesures de
placages à un avis conforme de la
recette l'idée derrière se comprendre on
en a déjà discuté en commission mais il
s'agit quand même d'un dispositif
particulièrement lourd à mettre en œuvre
pour la cèpe et qui doit être réservé à
mon avis aux cas les plus problématique
à l'égard des libertés publiques alors
c'est pourquoi s'agissant plus
particulièrement de la redirection du
nom de domaine vers un service sécurisé
de lentilles l'article prévoit qu'une
telle mesure ne peut excéder une durée
de deux mois
réconductible et une seule fois en cas
de persistance de la menace et après
avis de larsep cette mesure doit cesser
son délai lorsque la menace est
maîtrisée et les autres mesures sont
également soumis au contrôle de l'ARCEP
qui dispose d'un accès permanent aux
données collect ées par l'ancien de plus
l'ensemble des mesures ordonnées par
l'ancien susceptible de recours devant
le juge administratif dans les
conditions du droit commun alors
l'ensemble de ces garanties me paraît
suffisant dans ce cadre avis défavorable
merci monsieur le ministre
merci
députés le débat qu'on a eu sur les
amendements précédents doit nous
permettre peut-être de replacer ces
mesures administratives dans je dirais
le panorama des mesures de filtrage
aujourd'hui existantes et notamment
celle qui ont été cités le retrait en 24
heures des contenus terroristes et le
retrait des contenus pédopornographiques
on a là notamment s'agissant des
contenus pédopornographiques des
événements dans des quantités très
nombreuses l'année dernière c'est 74000
demandes de retrait de contenu
pédopornographique qui ont été adressés
par les autorités
aux hébergeurs
ce qui est poursuivi par les articles
dont nous discutons ce matin ce sont des
atteintes manifestes à la sécurité
nationale qui se chiffre ou qui se
chiffreront en une ou deux dizaines
maximum d'événements dans lesquels la
sécurité nationale est engagée parce
qu'il y a une attaque coordonnée et
massive sur un certain nombre
d'autorité ou d'opérateurs d'importance
vitale on est là donc dans des
événements qui sont certes d'une
sévérité très importante mais qui sont
en nombre extrêmement restreint et je
crois qu'il faut aussi lire ces articles
dans ce contexte là et ne pas les
ramener à la comparaison avec d'autres
mesures administratives de filtrage
comme celles que j'évoquais à l'instant
et puis s'agissant de 7 amendement
madame la rapporteur a bien décrit le
contrôle qui est réalisé par l'ARCEP
puisque l'ARCEP est notifié dès lors
qu'une demande de filtrage est réalisée
que l'ARCEP peut s'opposer à ce que le
filtrage continue si la recette
considère qu'il n'est pas approprié que
la vie conforme de l'arsèques est
nécessaire lorsqu'une un renouvellement
de la demande et est faite et que dans
ces conditions la vie de du Conseil
d'État qui a été donné sur cet article
est très clair c'est à dire que le les
le cadre dans lequel ces demandes de
filtrage peuvent être réalisées et
proportionnées à l'objectif poursuivi
merci
monsieur bernalicis
[Musique]
et donc oui bah non mais finalement
c'est que deux dizaines on a le temps
parce qu'il y en a que deux dizaines
mais non mais c'est la sévérité de
l'attaque qui nous pose la logique
voudrait que parce que l'attaque est
sévère
et ben il faut des moyens qui puissent
être énormes sur un temps très court
c'est quand même sinon on est foutu avec
un truc pareil on est foutu quoi tout le
monde va rigoler n'importe quel acteur
du monde va se dire la France c'est
vraiment des rigolo moi je pense qu'on
est des rigolos vu les moyens qu'on met
à Annecy et d'un certain nombre
d'agences et d'autorité administratives
indépendante chargée de contrôler aussi
leur action ça c'est vrai ça c'est vrai
mais du coup sachant tout ça on peut pas
juste se dire il y a des garanties
juridiques dans le texte formel
parce qu'on sait que derrière elle le
pourront être mise en oeuvre
correctement donc chacun a sa manière là
les camarades socialistes proposent
qu'il y ait une autorité qui donne un
avis conforme pour donner une garantie
supplémentaire alors que nous même on
sait que ces autorités sont des lames
parfois et souvent émoussées pour
pouvoir aller faire leur contrôle
l'objectif mais enfin on se dit c'est
mieux que si c'était pire et même ça
c'est de trop pour vous donc plus on
avance dans l'examen de cet article puis
je me dis qu'il est
urgent de ne pas donner ses prérogatives
là à l'ancien de rester à l'état actuel
du droit qui permet déjà de faire face
aux attaques puisqu'on n'a pas bien
compris ce qu'on allait pouvoir empêcher
aujourd'hui avec cet article qu'on
n'empêche pas déjà aujourd'hui merci je
vais mettre l'amendement 171 qui a reçu
la vie défavorable de la commission et
du gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre n'est pas adopté madame
Thomas le 170 oui merci madame la
Présidente un amendement de lisibilité
du texte avec les députés socialistes
nous souhaitons rajouter au dispositions
de mise en œuvre des mesures prévues par
l'article 32 de la LPM une disposition
supplémentaire qui permet au juge des
référés d'intervenir suivant la
procédure du référé liberté nous
considérons que la République doit
rester un état de droit en toute
circonstance même lorsqu'il s'agit de
sujets ayant trait à la Défense
nationale nous demandons de rendre cet
élément visible dans le texte pour les
opérateurs mais aussi pour tout citoyen
il y a nécessité de mentionner cet
élément dans le texte tout citoyen
devrait être en mesure de comprendre la
loi et nous voyons cet amendement comme
un enjeu d'intelligibilité je vous
remercie
merci Madame la rapporteur à Villa
commission merci madame la Présidente
peut-être pour rappel le référé liberté
est à la disposition de tout juste ici
plusieurs conditions prévues à l'article
L520 du code de justice administratif
que l'administration est portée une
attente grave à une liberté fondamentale
ce que le juge apprécie une concréto que
l'attente soit manifestement illégale
qu'elle soit imputable à une personne
morale de droit public ou un organisme
de droit privé chargé d'un service
public et enfin que la requête soit
justifiée par une urgence à agir pour
faire cesser cette attente alors si ces
critères sont réunis le recours au
référé liberté sera naturellement
possible donc je suis pas favorable à
cet ajout parce qu'il est déjà satisfait
endroit constant sauf à rajouter cette
mention à chaque nouveau dispositif que
nous créons pour AD Apter notre droit
alors convenait que ça alourdirait
vraiment considérablement nos codes donc
avis défavorable merci Monsieur le
Ministre même avis monsieur léoman
oui bonjour madame la présidente
Madame la rapporteur là il est proposé
simplement de rajouter dans la loi le
fait que on puisse dans les cas qui sont
utiles pour le référé liberté qu'on
puisse le mettre dans la loi pour que
les gens puissent savoir quels sont les
droits qui sont les leurs il n'est
jamais grave de rappeler dans la loi les
droits qui sont ceux des citoyens vers
là ça vous ça c'est pas un amendement
qui vous coûte quelque chose c'est pas
un amendement qui crée de la dépense
c'est pas un amendement qui crée des
problèmes particuliers c'est un
amendement qui rappelle aux citoyens
leurs droits dans le cadre de la loi il
y a un risque que la loi que vous nous
proposez aujourd'hui soit abusive dans
un certain nombre de cas pour les
libertés publiques et il est donc normal
qu'on rappelle dans le cas où
effectivement la loi deviendrait abusive
quels sont les droits des citoyens et
des citoyens j'ai vraiment du mal à
comprendre pourquoi il est possible de
légiférer sur les drapeaux européens
mais que il n'est pas possible de juste
rajouter quels sont les droits qui sont
celles des des quels sont les droits qui
sont ceux des citoyennes et des citoyens
ça me semble pas coûteux et efficace
je comprends votre souci à ce que toute
public puisse comprendre d'avoir accès
donc
via le référé liberté mais quand vous
lisez ce que vous voulez rajouter le
contrôle juridictionnel sur les mesures
prises au titre du présent arctique
s'exerce notamment dans les conditions
prévues à l'article
l521-2 de code de justice administratif
est-ce que vous croyez que tous les
citoyens comprennent ce qui écrit là je
crois qu'on a besoin un avocat et donc
un avocat dirait aussi les droits à
cette personne merci
je vais mettre au bois cet amendement
170 qui a reçu un avis défavorable de la
commission et du gouvernement qui est
pour
quicontre n'est pas adopté des
amendements identiques le 837 monsieur
Saintoul
merci madame la Présidente bon là c'est
sur la conservation des données
c'est le paragraphe qui était introduit
en disant on va conserver des données
pendant 10 ans et en commission par le
fruit de l'équilibre entre le centre le
milieu et le centre de gravité
on n'est pas rentré sur la question de
pourquoi ces données pourquoi on avait
besoin de les conserver qu'est-ce qu'on
allait en faire et donc du coup derrière
essayer d'en déduire quelque chose de
encore une fois logique pas juste un
équilibre en disant bon bah parce que
l'équilibre entre 10 ans et zéro
peut-être que ça aurait été de la lignée
sur deux ans il y a tout un tas de de
données qui sont conservées pour une
durée de deux ans dans les dans les
cotes Code Sécurité intérêts il y a des
Dédé c'est un mois des fois c'est garder
les données que pendant un mois
notamment en matière de vidéo
surveillance et ça va être souvent un
délai d'un mois bon alors encore une
fois sur quoi on s'aligne c'est quoi le
raisonnement parce que si vous vous
dites juste ah bah on avait mis 10 faut
savoir trop bien pourquoi parce que 10
c'est un chiffre rond et les gens ont
râlé en disant 10 c'est peut-être un peu
trop long bah tiens on va couper en deux
et d'ailleurs 10 / 2 ça fait 5
ça me semble un peu limité comme
raisonnement pour conserver des données
de Jean qui peuvent être des données
sensibles parce que il y a quand même
dans nos droits fondamentaux de trois
bricoles sur la vie privée droit
conservation de ces données personnelles
bon donc on aimerait on aimerait
comprendre parce qu'on nous a même dit
voilà des fois quand il y a des menaces
on peut garder on nous a dit en
commission pour garder les données
pendant un an et demi deux ans ça arrive
que des attaquants reviennent alors un
an et demi deux ans bah on comprend
c'est ça c'est encore une fois c'est des
éléments objectifs en fonction de ce
qu'on sait des attaques qui se sont
répétées du retour d'expérience qu'on en
a et ce que aujourd'hui on a des
attaquants qu'on connaît depuis 10 ans
sachant qu'en plus les technologies
d'attaque en disant ont largement changé
donc gardez les données dans 10 ans en
matière de de numérique franchement
je me demande de quoi vous allez faire
avec vos données de 10 ans à votre déjà
complètement obsolète bon je vois je
vois je comprends pas le sens et 5 ans
bon pas plus non plus merci je vais
Monsieur Madame la rapporteur avis de la
commission
c'est assez étonnant alors je suis
contre votre amendement car il reviendra
s'il était adopté à supprimer les
modalités en fait qui encadrent la
conservation des données recueillies au
titre de l'article 32 ça c'est quand
même jour uniquement très très
insécurisant et à mon avis c'est pas
votre volonté alors j'entends plutôt
qu'il s'agit d'un amendement à d'appel
qui ont tant s'opposé aux nouvelles où
autorisation aux matières de collecte de
données son motif légitime apparent or
l'alinéa visée concerne les cas où des
cibles attaquants ont sciemment exploité
un nom de domaine au fond de porter
atteinte à la sécurité nationale il
s'agit d'obtenir des éléments sur le
comportement de l'attaquant et son mode
opératoire afin de neutraliser la menace
identifier les victimes et mieux
prévenir les attaques et l'alinéa
prévoit justement des délais de
conservation limitées toujours sur le
contrôle de lacep d'ailleurs dans son
avis sur le projet de loi le Conseil
d'État observe que le dispositif
envisagé justifié par la sauvegarde des
intérêts fondamentaux de la nation et
par la prévention des attentes à l'ordre
public
j'ai néanmoins souhaité encadrer la
durée de conservation de ces données on
la diminuant de 10 à 5 ans et je suis
pour cette raison opposée à la
suppression de cette aliéna si monsieur
le ministre
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés peut-être rappeler
ce que prévoit cette alinéa 14 après
tout l'article 32 et permet à Annecy de
demander le filtrage d'un nom de domaine
pas de lien évident avec la collecte de
données
relative à l'attaque mais en réalité une
collègue de données peut intervenir si
l'annecy au moment de demander le
filtrage du nom de domaine réoriente un
certain nombre de flux associés à
l'attaque vers un serveur sécurisé par
l'annecy et c'est à ce moment là que le
serveur sécurisé de l'ancie va percevoir
certaines des données relatives à
l'attaque mais on est sur un champ
extrêmement limité c'est la raison pour
laquelle le gouvernement considère que
le compromis ou en tout cas le choix qui
a été retenu par la commission des 5 ans
sur cet article comme sur les autres est
un est un bon compromis j'ajoute que
c'est peut-être à l'article 35 que nous
examinerons tout à l'heure que le
passage de 10 ans à 5 ans n'avait pas
été réalisé en commission mais nous
aurons tout à l'heure le l'occasion
d'examiner un amendement de madame
Thomas qui vient lui aussi ramener de 10
ans à 5 ans ce délai pour l'article 35
et donc sur ces quatre articles du 32 au
35 on est passé de 10 ans à 5 ans ce qui
paraît approprié c'est donc un avis
défavorable sur ses amendes monsieur
bernalicis
merci Madame la président bon vous
admettrez que il n'y a aucune espèce de
d'argumentation sur pourquoi 5 plutôt
que 10 pourquoi 10 étaient pertinent
avant pourquoi ça les plus maintenant
sauf à dire bah on avait mis 10 et
maintenant 5 c'est plus protecteur parce
que c'est moins que 10 bon après je vais
dire à un moment donné il faut nous
donner des arguments de fonds des trucs
parce que quand vous nous dites moi
intérêt fondamentaux de la nation je
suis transi et je me dis pourquoi pas
les conserver à vie ces données
puisqu'elles sont sensibles et que ces
intérêts fondamentaux de la nation
atteint alors de public je suis un peu
plus mitigé parce que on boit on peut
mettre tout et n'importe quoi dans le
public
nous pourrions être considérés comme
portant atteinte à l'ordre public
macronien et ce serait pas complètement
faux mais
ouais c'est le chaos donc la question
c'est
quelle garantie on se donne en la
matière il est inscrit dans cette dans
cette article alinéa pardon que en
réalité les données personnelles doivent
être détruites immédiatement parce que
vous l'avez dit Monsieur le Ministre
quand vous prenez un flux de données de
d'une cible qui s'est fait attaquer et
que vous le déroutez vers un serveur
sécurisé pour pouvoir l'analyser le
circonscrire et et
empêcher l'attaque quoi bah vous prenez
tout les flux de données des tournées
enfin tout ce qui allait sur le nom de
domaine précédent on va aller sur le
serveur sécurisé absolument tout si
c'est un site commercial bah les données
d'un grand groupe j'en sais rien voilà
au hasard toutes les données
personnelles les gens qui vont avoir
leur login password enfin tout ce qui
tout va être dessus donc effectivement
vous prenez la précaution de dire on va
supprimer les données personnelles par
quels moyens est-ce que c'est un
algorithme qu'il faut automatiquement
est-ce que c'est un agent en tant que
tel qu'est-ce qu'on va conserver qui va
contrôler vraiment ou pas est-ce que
l'art c'est pas vraiment les moyens de
contrôler tout ça
bon alors là si vous ne dites que oui
garantie formelle dans le texte moi
enfin dans le monde réel la vérité c'est
que il va y avoir des tas de données
dont on ne sera même pas distinguer ce
qui est de la donnée personnelle ou pas
personnelle et qu'on va garder pendant
des années et qui pourront être utilisés
je sais pas trop quoi et il faut que on
vous croit sur votre bonne parole et sur
l'action forcément géniale de nos
services qui n'ont aucune faille enfin
aucune faille
juste un petit article qui vient de
tomber sur la cnctr qui qui donne
normalement nous fait réfléchir oui
monsieur le ministre
merci Madame la présente non ce n'est
pas ce que prévoit l'article ce que
prévoit l'article c'est que dans le cas
où puisqu'on évoquait tout à l'heure la
gradation de la mesure puisqu'on peut
avoir on peut être face à un
propriétaire ou intitulé de noms de
domaine de bonne foi c'est par exemple
le cas d'une entreprise ou d'un site tel
que celui que vous décrivez alors la
redirection ne peut pas être faite vers
un serveur de 26 c'est uniquement
lorsque le nombre de domaines est détenu
par un assaillant ou en tout cas qui a
été acquis à des fins malveillantes que
la redirection peut avoir lieu donc je
veux clarifier les choses sur ce point
merci je vais mettre au moins
l'amendement 800 les amendements 837
identiques qui ont reçu un avis
défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement qui est pour qui est contre
ils ne sont pas adoptés le 173 madame
Thomas
merci madame la Présidente pourquoi 5
ans la question des délais pour la
conservation des données est une
question intéressante
je ne suis pas membre de la commission
des lois mais membres de la commission
de la défense et quand ce débat a eu
lieu en commission des lois nous étions
déjà très occupés en commission défense
mais nous avons bien entendu les retours
de ce débat qui a causé des soucis à
Madame la rapporteur durant les travaux
préparatoires pour justifier ces 5 ans
de conservation des données la question
la conservation des données n'est pas
neutre en termes de protection des
libertés plus on réduit la durée de
conservation et mieux le droit se porte
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
proposons de substituer aux mots simples
le mot 2 et se donner 5 ans pour
exploiter les données nous considérons
que c'est renvoyés aux calendes great au
calendes grec pardon l'exploitation
immédiate et efficace de ces données
nous proposons donc pour une meilleure
efficacité de l'administration une durée
de deux ans pour l'exploitation de ces
données
merci Madame la rapporteur
merci madame la Présidente chers
collègues donc vous considérez que cette
cette réduction de lait à de 10 à 5
c'est arbitraire mais là aussi la
décision s'est appuyé quand même sur les
échanges avec l'ancien qui quand elle
fait des recherches d'antériorité donc
elle n'a pas besoin parfois considéré
comme
cette délai c'est délai était nécessaire
disons a été trop longue et deux ans
c'est trop court pour essayer de
comprendre le mode opératoire ben oui on
cherche toujours quand même la mesure
entre être efficace et entre aussi
donner des données des garanties ce qui
est beaucoup plus facile que d'avoir des
avis extrêmement tranchés donc avis
défavorable
merci monsieur le ministre
merci madame la présidente Madame la
rapporteur a très bien parlé peut-être
simplement ajouter à son argumentaire
que il y a effectivement des cas avérés
ou des assaillants ont pu quelques
années après allant au-delà de 5 ans
utilisé des architectures d'attaque qui
avait été mis en place
et bien pour pour prendre le contrôle
d'un certain nombre de serveurs etc dans
leur immense majorité les
la durée si l'on peut dire de ces
attaques est inférieur à 50 donc en
passant de 10 ans à 5 ans on exclut
peut-être quelques rares attaques pour
lesquelles les les
infrastructures avaient été placées très
très longtemps en amont mais avec cinq
ans on englobe l'essentiel de ces
attaques et ça paraît le bon compromis
en tout cas le point d'atterrissage de
la Commission sur cet article comme sur
les autres s'agissant de la durée de
conservation des données et le bon
merci Monsieur Léo man
merci Madame présidente bon alors là on
comprend plus rien parce que vous nous
dites 10 ans pour la conservation des
données c'est trop au début c'est ce que
vous proposiez c'est en commission qu'on
a inventé pour passer à 5 ans bon
ensuite vous nous dites 5 ans c'est bien
2 ans ça serait pas assez ok mais la
question c'est pourquoi et le seul qui a
répondu c'est monsieur le ministre qui
nous a dit un pourquoi mais le pourquoi
nous dit que les architectures peuvent
être plus longues que 5 ans donc
pourquoi on a mis 5 ans à ce moment-là
il faut mettre plus si jamais faut
mettre faut mettre 5 ans et demi ou 6
ans ou 7 ans vous voyez ce qu'on veut
dire ce qu'on veut dire c'est que quand
vous limitez des droits il faut nous
donner des bonnes raisons de le faire
parce que sinon on fait n'importe quoi
et puis ensuite on commence avec des
lois par exemple sur la sécurité
intérieure qui finissent par être
utilisé contre des militants écologistes
par exemple ça arrive ça arrive assez
fréquemment qu'on nous dise que au nom
de la lutte anti-terroriste il va
falloir faire 6 à ça et puis que à la
fin ou de l'ordre public il a raison
monsieur Bernal ici il faut faire si ça
parce que comme ça plus jamais rien
n'arrivera qui sera dramatique c'est pas
grave on fait une loi sur la sécurité
par an ça pose jamais de problème et ça
règle jamais les problèmes non plus et
puis à la fin les droits sont de plus en
plus menacés et là par exemple dans les
prochains trucs que vous nous annoncez
vous nous dites ah bah maintenant va
mettre des mouchards dans les téléphones
voilà et petit à petit comme ça on petit
à petit comme ça on réduit les droits on
réduit les droits on réduit les droits
des lois qui sont faites pour l'entité
terrorisme sont utilisés dans d'autres
sujets ça ne pose pas de problème et là
sur un petit sujet sur un petit sujet
vous êtes même pas capable de nous dire
pourquoi 5 ans 10 ans 2 ans c'est bien
ou c'est pas bien voilà vous avez aucun
argument qui soit un argument rationnel
c'est ça qu'on vous demande on vous
demande des arguments rationnels c'est
tout merci Monsieur la tombe
merci merci madame le Président pourquoi
le 10 ans a priori quand on a eu la
discussion c'était une volonté de se
caler sur un délai de prescription
habituel 10 ans en matière dans ces
matières là sur un délit on est sur du
10 ans et donc il semblait avoir un bon
réflexe le vrai souci c'est que deux ans
c'est pas assez aujourd'hui nous avons à
cause de la coopération internationale
nous avons des délais qui sont beaucoup
plus longs nous avons des instructions
qui sont faites par d'autres pays qui
nous demandent de la coopération sur du
One à Cry et wanakry c'était 2017 nous
avons besoin de délais supérieur à 2 ans
en revanche on sait pertinemment et les
auditions l'ont montré que 10 ans ça ne
sert à rien parce que si on n'a pas
trouvé les personnes et si on n'a pas de
coopération dans les 5 ans qui suivent
une attaque on n'arrive pas à identifier
les personnes c'est pour ça qu'en
commission est arrivé sur ce compromis
de 5 ans deux c'est trop court parce que
on a encore des attaques de 2017 qu'on
est en train d'instruire ou sur lequel
il y a des demandes de coopération
d'autres pays
elles ont été mais non parce que vous
chers collègues chers collègues les
demandes ont été faites et ensuite une
fois que les demandes ont été faites
allanci les données ayant été gardées 5
ans on peut les transmettre à l'autorité
judiciaire donc elles ont été gelées par
une autorité judiciaire donc il y a pas
il y a pas de souci là-dessus donc c'est
pour ça qu'on est arrivé sur ce délai de
5 ans qui est le délai qui aujourd'hui
permet à l'ensemble de nos de nos
correspondants dans les pays avec
lesquels nous travaillons sur la super
partie cybersécurité de pouvoir nous
faire des demandes dans les temps et
qu'on puisse être efficace merci je vais
mettre au voile amendement 173 qui a
reçu un avis défavorable de la
commission et du gouvernement qui est
pour
qui est contre il n'est pas adopté je
vous indique que sur l'article 32 je
suis saisie par le groupe démocrate
d'une demande de scrutin public que
j'annonce dans l'enceinte de l'Assemblée
nationale monsieur gordanoff
l'amendement 1273 merci madame la
Présidente c'est dans la même logique
l'amendement 170 de ma collecte Thomas
tout à l'heure
en commission on avait proposé une
procédure Haddock de de recours vous
nous aviez dit Madame la rapporteur que
il y avait le référé liberté et donc
c'était largement suffisant par cet
amendement nous souhaitons simplement
que le référé liberté soit garanti soit
de fait et qu'on puisse pas opposer une
ircevabilité sur sur les injonctions et
l'édition prise par l'annecy dans le cas
de cet article je vous remercie merci
madame le rapporteur avis de la
commission
avis défavorables même argument que tout
à l'heure sort l'amendement de madame
Thomas merci monsieur le ministre
merci
monsieur bernalicis
c'est vrai qu'on a eu le débat un peu
rapidement tout à l'heure sur le sujet
administratif et sur le référé liberté
ça rejoint les délais qu'on avait
proposé de 72 heures et vous nous dites
bah ouais mais c'est déjà présent dans
la loi puis Jean-Pierre il reprend un
avocat et puis débrouillez-vous puis
l'objectif de toute façon c'est pas de
faire valoir les droits c'est d'intérêt
d'arrêter l'attaque et de pouvoir
conserver les données de l'attaque pour
pouvoir décrire des architectures enfin
la sécurité nationale quoi truc voilà ça
rigole pas donc vos machins d'aller
saisir le gène administratif chers
collègues bon c'est pas le sujet quoi
gros c'est ça qu'on entend très bien
mais on comprend toujours pas pourquoi
il faut 50 10 ans deux ans 72 heures 48
heures on a l'impression que votre seul
but c'est que ça passe le fil du Conseil
constitutionnel il soit le plus haut
possible par rapport au filtre du
Conseil constitutionnel une sorte de
crash test permanent sur jusque où est
prêt à aller le Conseil continuel parce
que allons plus loin possible en
fonction de ce qui passera
non c'est pas comme ça qu'on doit
raisonner c'est pas possible dans un
état de droit c'est pas comme ça qu'on
doit raisonner on doit raisonner sur les
arguments logiques rationnels pertinents
et qui doivent permettre les voix de
recours sinon c'est autre chose qu'on
fait c'est autre chose et Monsieur le
Ministre et collègue la tombe les
attaques de la 5 ans etc c'est pas les
données exactes de l'attaque dont on a
besoin de toute façon les appuis en
l'état actuel de la de la de la
situation et quand on a une attaque on
s'écar on est capable de théoriser
l’architecture qui a été utilisée pour
le faire et ça on peut la conserver sans
avoir à conserver l'ensemble des données
attaquantes voilà bon et s'il y a une
enquête judiciaire les données seront
conservées sous scellées le temps des
besoins de l'enquête en tant que tel
donc c'est plus le même sujet non plus
c'est plus le même cadre donc bon moi à
la fin je veux bien qu'on nous raconte
des carabistouls mais votez une loi
comme celle-là et des moyens exorbitants
du droit sur la base de carabistoul bah
ouais tout il met dans le Nord on dit
carabistoule c'est comme ça et donc bon
je suis pas ça va pas du tout quoi et en
plus quand on parle de garantie devant
les administrative
oui merci madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues
simplement un mot les lois inutiles
affaiblissent les noix nécessaires nous
avons un code de justice administrative
extrêmement bien fait qui prévoit les
conditions de recours au référé liberté
il est absurde sur un sujet ou sur un
autre de rajouter que ça relève du
référé liberté c'est déjà dans le code
de justice administrative
la discussion au niveau où elle est on
est sur une agence du gouvernement qui
dépend directement des pouvoirs du
Premier ministre et qui va prendre des
mesures donc c'est l'exécutif qui prend
des mesures qui resteraient les libertés
publiques donc il faut à minima prévoir
je trouve déjà qu'on est dans un cadre
quand même un peu particulier de
d'équipe des pouvoirs mais je pense
qu'il faut à minima prévoir une
procédure
devant juge administratif et la question
du référé
la question de la recevabilité etc donc
c'est pas automatique il faut écrire
dans ce texte quelle est la procédure il
faut qu'il y ait une procédure dans tous
les cas et ça peut pas être à la main du
juge de dire c'est pas recevable parce
que
sur ce texte là c'est pas l'urgence
c'est pas etc donc il faut une procédure
on en avait proposé une en commission
vous nous avez dit non il y a le référé
inscrivons le référé liberté c'est quoi
le problème
je comprends pas
merci je vais mettre ouais c'est
amendement
1273 qui a reçu un avis défavorable de
la commission et du gouvernement qui est
pour
qui contre il n'est pas adopté monsieur
la tombe le 1658 oui merci Madame
Présidente il s'agit d'un amendement que
nous avions nous avions débattu en
commission des lois qui vise à changer
le mot surcoût par le mot coup pourquoi
parce que et vous l'avez dit Monsieur le
Ministre on va être face à peut-être
deux dizaines de d'attaque par an qui
vont concerner être concernés par
certains articles 32 mais qui seront les
attaques massives et coordonnées et pour
lequel les opérateurs vont avoir à faire
des investissements très important pour
pouvoir répondre à l'article 32 on n'est
pas simplement sur ce qui se passe pour
les retraites contenu qui existaient
déjà et donc à chaque fois qu'on en
rajoute on peut éventuellement parler de
surcoût là on va être les opérateurs
votre projet de faire des
investissements très importants pour
pouvoir faire de la redirection vers des
serveurs sécurisés de l'annecy par
exemple sur des attaques coordonnées
massives avec des flux de données très
important avec des mesures qu'ils vont
devoir prendre et donc des
investissements sur des logiciels qui
permettent de faire du filtrage ou
permettre de faire que le flux arrive
directement sur les serveurs qui est
beaucoup plus important que ce que nous
avons d'habitude sur la question des
retraits de contenu terroristes ou
pédopornographiques et donc aujourd'hui
leur imposer simplement le mot surcoût
d'abord comment est-ce qu'on définit et
ensuite le vrai problème c'est que ces
opérateurs s'ils font ces
investissements ça sera au détriment du
fonctionnement normal de des services
qu'ils opèrent puisque ça va opérer leur
capacités d'investissement donc il est
normal aujourd'hui que puisque nous
demandons aux opérateurs des mesures
supplémentaires qui sont exceptionnelles
et qui ne sont pas habituelles et qui
donc pour lesquelles ils vont avoir des
investissements importants à faire que
les coûts soient supportés par la
collectivité et donc par le gouvernement
merci Madame la rapporteur
merci madame la Présidente nous avons
déjà eu ces échanges plusieurs fois bon
moi je réinterroger l'ancien c'est vrai
que je me base là dessus qui assure que
l'article 35 n'implique aucune dépense
d'investissement de la part des
opérateurs concernés et comme l'a dit
aussi monsieur le ministre il s'agit
d'une dizaine de mesures de filtrage par
an ce nombre pareil quand même
raisonnable et permettra à une exécution
par des agents d'or et déjà embauchés
sans qu'il soit besoin de mettre en
place un système de traitement
automatisé des saisons en revanche la
notion de coût permet de couvrir les
dépenses de fonctionnement et donc les
éventuellement dépenses inhérentes à la
masse salariale mobilisée par les
opérateurs donc en commission on a
adopté un avis défavorable moi je
personnellement là je parle
personnellement je plutôt j'hésite ite
entre le favorable et défavorable mais
parce que là j'avoue que je me base sur
ce qui m'a été avancée moi-même je n'ai
pas une vision très claire là-dessus je
le dis clairement donc
je maintiens le défavorable adopté en
commission et je laisse minutieux le
ministre s'exprimer merci Monsieur merci
madame le rapporteur monsieur le
ministre
merci Madame la présente mesdames et
messieurs les députés il s'agit donc
effectivement d'un dispositif qui permet
à l'ancien d'enjoindre aux opérateurs de
communication électroniques résolveurs
de DNS pardon de
de mettre en place des filtrages
la question correspondait effectivement
d'un
dédommagement plus important si des
investissements devaient être concédés
par ces acteurs pour la mise en place ou
pour l'exécution de ces demandes de
filtrage or les acteurs en question sont
d'ores et déjà assujettis à des demandes
de filtrage dont j'ai dit tout à l'heure
quels étaient très nombreuses
en raison des obligations ou en tout cas
des mesures administratives dont ils
peuvent faire l'objet
il convient donc effectivement et c'est
l'objectif en tout cas de l'amendement
de s'assurer que les dépenses
supplémentaires mais en fonctionnement
soit bien dédommagé et qu'on n'impose
pas à ces acteurs des actes sans les
dédommager pour pour leur mise en œuvre
c'est le l'objectif de qui est poursuivi
par l'article qui indique que les
surcoûts c'est-à-dire les dépenses de
fonctionnement supplémentaires
doivent pouvoir être compensées par
l'État et c'est la raison pour laquelle
le
la proposition qui est faite dans votre
amendement d'aller plus loin et
d'englober les coûts nous paraît
excessive et nous paraît pouvoir
engendrer des charges très importantes
pour les finances publiques qui iraient
au-delà des charges effectivement
engendrées par ces mesures nouvelles
dont vous avez rappelé que elles vont
concerner un nombre assez limité de cas
c'est donc une demande de retrait ou un
avis défavorable
merci monsieur bernalicis
merci madame la Présidente donc là on a
prévu dans cet alinéa de pouvoir
dédommager des opérateurs qui auraient
pour obligation de respecter la loi
quand même assez un concept intéressant
de dédommager des gens parce qu'ils
devront respecter la loi
je sais pas s'il y a des cas de figure
équivalents précédents peut-être dans
les réquisitions de la semaine
réquisition me semble-t-il après si
c'est vrai que si on renationalisait le
secteur des télécommunications on aurait
peut-être moins de difficultés
effectivement merci et donc se pose la
question alors du coup le collègue la
tombe va jusqu'au bout de la logique il
dit bah attends attendez la sécurité
nationale ok d'accord très bien mais
enfin si vous n'en demandez de mettre en
place des machins pour arrêter les
assaillants des gros filtres et tout
nous on n'a pas que ça à faire chez les
opérateurs ça nous coûte des sous et
nous on aimerait bien juste en gagner de
l'argent quand on est opérateur de
télécommunications fournisseurs d'accès
Internet etc bref plutôt que d'avoir à
faire des machins pour le compte des
états sur le sur la sécurité nationale
vous voyez la logique donc à limite mon
cœur balance en me disant bah allongé au
bout de la logique effectivement c'est
d'intérêt public c'est public donc c'est
au public de le supporter et pas au
fournisseur d'accès et en même temps de
me dire mais attendez la sécurité c'est
l'affaire de tous c'est pas c'est pas un
slogan à vous ça
de sécurité c'est l'affaire de tous le
continuum de sécurité dans ce beau
continuum il pourrait pas apprendre à
leur charge le fait que leur propre
système ne soit pas utilisé à des fins
malveillantes nos propres systèmes de
télécommunication ne soient pas utilisé
à des femmes malveillantes donc moi je
suis plutôt
défavorable à l'amendement du collègue
la tombe au final de du raisonnement je
viens de vous exposer parce que je pense
qu'ils peuvent mettre un peu la main à
la poche peut-être qu'il faut mettre
complètement la main à la poche
d'ailleurs parce que c'est dans leur
intérêt aussi assez fournisseurs
merci Monsieur la tombe
madame le Président ça sera pas un
retrait on maintiendra l'argument que
vous donnez monsieur le ministre qui est
de dire que c'est quelque chose qui
existe déjà et qu'on est simplement sur
une couche supplémentaire c'est pas ce
que nous disent les opérateurs dans le
cadre des auditions que nous avons pu
mener et c'est la divergence que nous
avons entre le travail parlementaire et
le travail de proposition de des
services que qui vous a été fait
aujourd'hui les opérateurs nous disent
qu'il va falloir faire des
investissements très importants pour
répondre à vos obligations parce que on
sera peut-être sur un son de cas
relativement limité mais avec des flux
massifs qu'il va falloir rediriger vers
des serveurs sécurisés de l'ancien ou en
mettant des filtrage et donc ça
nécessite des investissements qui se
feront forcément au détriment des
investissements qu'ils feront sur les
réseaux pour la collectivité pour le cas
général pour l'ensemble des de nos
concitoyens donc c'est ça aujourd'hui
que nous visons et accessoirement ça
permettra de répondre à une question de
de mon collègue de l'autre côté les
mystique si on dit coup à la place de
surcoût peut-être que ça modera le
nombre de demandes de redirection de DNS
et de filtrage de la part de l'ansy et
donc c'est une mesure de contrôle
éventuellement
monsieur le ministre
merci madame la Présidente j'imagine que
les opérateurs de télé vous les acteurs
visés par l'article ont signalé à la
représentation nationale les surcoutes
très considérable ou les coûts pour eux
ce la mise en oeuvre de ces mesures de
filtrage mais pour revenir à la
légistique
dans la LCEN les les capacités qui sont
données à la DGCCRF par exemple pour
faire cesser ou pour opérer un filtrage
capacité qui a été mobilisée pour le
déréférencement
notamment alors c'est pas une mesure de
filtrage mais pour le déréférencement de
de wish dans ce dans la de la plateforme
oui dans ce cas précis la LCN prévoit
une compensation des surcoûts pour les
coûts de fonctionnement
merci je vais mettre au bout à
l'amendement 1658 qui a reçu un avis
défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement qui est pour
quiconque il n'est pas adopté je vais
mettre au bois l'article 32 qui fait
l'objet d'un scrut d'un public que j'ai
annoncé tout à l'heure dans l'enceinte
de l'Assemblée nationale votant 62
exprimés 58 majorité 30 pour 51 contre 7
l'Assemblée nationale a adopté nous
passons maintenant à l'article 33 avec
Madame chassagnol
oui merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Ministre madame la rapporteur donc
cet article prévoit la communication à
l'ancy de certaines données de cash de
serveur de système de noms de domaine
pour que chacun comprenne bien ce qui
est visé ici il faut rappeler que les
résolveurs DNS sont les machines qui
font le lien entre un nom de domaine et
l'adresse IP d'une machine qui va
formuler une demande pour atteindre ce
nom de domaine afin de répondre
rapidement à l'utilisateur ces serveurs
conservent des données qui sont dites de
cash or ces données ne peuvent pas être
transmises aujourd'hui à l'annecy alors
qu'elle les éclairait sur les
infrastructures informatiques utilisées
par les cyber-attaquants en ayant accès
désormais aux causes des cyberattaques
et non seulement à leurs effets par
conséquent il est proposé avec cet
article d'obtenir la copie des données
de cache des serveurs DNS en permettant
d'obtenir les noms de domaine les
adresses IP des machines utilisées et
l'euro d'attache des demandes il sera
ainsi possible de connaître avec
précision les modes opératoires des
cyber-attaquants ces données sont donc
stratégiques pour perfectionner nos
dispositifs de détection des menaces et
de contre-attaques et ce dispositif est
évidemment l'objet d'un contrôle de
l'ARCEP je le précise parce qu'il est
inscrit à l'article 35 du projet de loi
et pas et pas l'article à l'article
examiné ici donc l'article précise
également d'autres garanties qui sont
importantes en excluant les données
identifiantes de la copie autorisée par
l'ansy on en a longuement parlé en
commission j'aurais d'ailleurs
l'occasion de défendre un amendement
pour préciser l'anonymisation des
données qui peuvent être recueillies par
l'ansy c'est donc la stratégie de
cyberdéfense que nous portons avec ces
articles qui vise à adapter nos
connaissances et nos réactions à
l'évolution des menaces tout en
préservant l'équilibre fondamental qui
nous est cher et qui nous est cher
collègue entre la nécessité de se
défendre et nos droits et libertés
merci madame la députée madame le Hainan
merci madame la Présidente cet article
permet aux agents de l'ancien aux fins
de détection et de caractérisation des
attaques informatiques des destinataires
des données techniques non identifiantes
enregistrées temporairement sur les
serveurs des opérateurs de communication
électronique
des fournisseurs de systèmes de
résolution de noms de domaine une
nouvelle fois notre groupe c'est exprime
en faveur de cet article dont plusieurs
précisions ont été apportées en
commission que ce soit sur le cadre des
pouvoirs conférés à Annecy les délais de
conservation des données ou encore les
avis des autorités indépendantes la
suppression des opérateurs de
communication électroniques du champ de
cet article nous apparaît également une
bonne chose enfin préciser que les IP
sources ne peuvent être ni recueillis ni
exploiter nous a paru nécessaire le
groupe horizon redépose un amendement
qui nous paraît cependant très important
et que nous avons retravaillé à
retravailler à l'issue de la commission
il s'agit de préciser que les données
transmises aux agents de l'annecy
doivent être anonymisés par les
fournisseurs de systèmes de résolution
de noms de domaine dans ce contexte nous
espérons également qu'il nous sera
précisé lors de nos débats quelles sont
les catégories de données
identifiantes et celles qui ne le sont
pas je vous remercie merci madame la
députée nous passons maintenant aux
amendements à l'article avec le 1270
monsieur Yordanov merci madame la
Présidente je m'excuse par avance de
revenir sur cette question là mais j'y
reviendrai encore sur les deux articles
suivants c'est la question de la notion
de sécurité nationale
que je propose ici et par voie
d'amendement de remplacer par les
fondamentaux de la nation qui au moins
sont quelque chose de précis et listé
quelque part vous nous avez dit faut pas
renvoyer au code pénal en commission
vous avez dit il faut pas renvoyer au
code de sécurité intérieure alors bon je
veux bien qu'on renvoie nulle part mais
à ce moment-là il faut faire quand même
la liste faut définir ce que c'est que
la notion de sécurité nationale vous
nous avez dit tout à l'heure d'aller
voir sur une décision du Conseil
constitutionnel je suis allé voir j'ai
pas trouvé en tout cas de définition
très précise donc j'aimerais que vous
nous disiez quelle est la décision à
laquelle vous faites référence et
qu'est-ce que dit le Conseil
constitutionnel pour caractériser
exactement qu'est-ce que la sécurité
nationale parce que j'ai pas trouvé de
définition satisfaisante
et je pense que le législateur devrait
définir cette notion et ne pas laisser
en tout cas à la jurisprudence sauf à ce
qu'on est vraiment quelque chose de
précis mais à ce moment-là je vous
laisse nous dire ce que de quoi il
retourne exactement je vous remercie
madame la rapporteur avis de la
commission
merci madame la Présidente donc on s'est
déjà exprimé là-dessus même avis que
votre amendement ou 69 je précise quand
même qu'on est en commission on a quand
même fait évoluer les dispositifs parce
que les arts en dehors de l'article 32
il y avait aucune référence justement à
la défense et la sécurité nationale donc
on a quand même rattaché toutes les
articles à cette notion là ce qui me
semble le donner quand même déjà des
garanties beaucoup plus larges
avis défavorable merci monsieur le
ministre
[Musique]
merci madame la Présidente même avis que
Madame la rapporteur et même avis que
sur les amendements déposés à l'article
32 et pour répondre à votre question
monsieur le député
dans le cadre de l'examen d'une question
prioritaire de constitutionnalité qui
avait été déposée par des opérateurs de
communication électronique contre la loi
5G qui fait référence à la sécurité
nationale le Conseil constitutionnel a
jugé que la définition de sécurité
nationale elle était suffisamment
précisément définie par le législateur
merci Madame Lenon oui pardon monsieur
le ministre alors il s'agit de la
décision numéro 2020 882 du 5 février
merci Madame loïnan oui il paraît
peut-être aussi nécessaire de rappeler
assez régulièrement dans ses débats ce
matin que ce chapitre 5 rentre bien dans
le cadre de la loi de programmation
militaire c'est toujours c'est toujours
bon de le rappeler de temps en temps
puisque vraisemblablement de temps en
temps il y a des dérives vers des sujets
autres que ceux qui nous réunit ce matin
la loi de programmation militaire merci
Monsieur Yordanov
[Applaudissements]
bien lu la décision en question
le terme est accepté mais il n'est pas
défini dans cette décision
il y a aucune définition du terme
l'infusance des garanties du respect des
règles relatives à la permanence à
l'intégrité à la sécurité ou à la
disponibilité du réseau relative à la
confidentialité des messages transmis
des informations liées aux
communications c'est le seul truc qui se
rattache à s'écouter national je pense
que c'est ou alors c'est trop restrictif
et ça ne s'appliquera pas
aux prérogatifs de l'ancie ou alors on
est hors sujet mais dans tous les cas de
figure pourquoi le législateur ne
pourrait pas définir cette notion et j'y
reviendrai tout à l'heure mais je pense
que les juges européens aura un petit
souci avec avec cette imprécision je
vous remercie
merci non monsieur la tombe c'est un par
groupe donc je vais mettre aux voix cet
amendement 1270 qui a reçu un avis
défavorable de la commission du
gouvernement qui est pour
quiconque il n'est pas adopté madame la
rapporteur le 775 à Dax
merci avis du gouvernement favorable je
vais mettre au voie cette amendement qui
a reçu un avis favorable par définition
de la Commission et du gouvernement qui
est pour
quiconque il est adopté le 1275 monsieur
Yordanov
il est défendu
chez urdanov il est défendu
oui oui
défendu madame la rapporteur des
favorable monsieur le ministre je vais
le mettre au bois avec un avis
défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre il n'est pas adopté
monsieur la tombe le 1587 je vais les
retirer au profit des amendements 1626
et 1669 parce que c'était une discussion
que nous avions en commission des lois
le but c'était vraiment qu'on puisse
avoir cette discussion une réécriture ce
qui est le cas de la part de des
collègues Renaissance et horizon et donc
les amendements n'ont plus de raison
d'être donc je les retire au profit de
1626 et 1669 de Madame le vinan donc
vous retirez le 1587 et le 1618 merci
alors le 1626 madame chassagnol
merci madame la Présidente donc
effectivement c'est un amendement qui
vient préciser la contrainte sur les
données qui peuvent être recueillies par
l'ansy j'en profite aussi pour remercier
donc la collaboration qu'on a pu avoir
entre la Commission et la séance avec
leur rapporteur avec le gouvernement et
avec l'ancien à l'issue de ses
discussions donc il est apparu
qu'inscrire une liste de données
techniques ne permettrait pas d'être
réellement protecteur pour l'anonymat de
ces données car elles peuvent évoluer
elles peuvent finir par devenir
identifiantes donc on propose avec cet
amendement d'inscrire dans l'article que
les données transmises à Annecy doivent
être anonymisées autrement dit sans
présence des adresses IP sources afin de
préserver l'anonymat de l'utilisateur du
nom de domaine et de cibler seulement
les données qui pourront permettre de
reconstituer un type d'attaque il s'agit
donc de sécuriser l'anonymat des données
qui seront recueillies merci alors il y
a un pardon
il y a un amendement identique madame le
hennant le 1669
merci madame la Présidente donc le
présent amendement vise à préciser que
les données transmises aux agents de
l'annecy doivent être anonymisés par les
fournisseurs systèmes de résolution des
noms de domaine en effet ces données ne
doivent en aucun cas permettre une
identification comme cela est
explicitement écrit dans l'étude
d'impact de la présente loi cela vient
en complément de l'amendement de Madame
la rapporteur adopté en commission des
lois qui précisent que les données
techniques permettant d'identifier la
source de la connexion et celle
relatives aux équipements terminaux
utilisés ne peuvent être ni recueillis
ni exploiter
merci il y a sur ces deux amendements
identiques un sous amendement de Madame
la rapporteur le 1791 sous un monde de
Morad actionnelle rédactionnelle
monsieur donc Madame la rapporteur votre
avis sur les deux amendements
identiques
favorable parce que c'est une précision
utile du dispositif et à le décret en
Conseil d'État que nous avons souhaité
qu'ils soient prises après l'avis de la
CNIL précisera les modalités merci
monsieur le ministre
merci Madame la présente mesdames et
messieurs et députés même avis que la
rapporteur et c'est l'occasion comme je
l'avais fait pour l'article 32 de saluer
les travaux en commission qui ont permis
de d'affiner et de resserrer le
dispositif avec une mention faite à la
sécurité nationale avec un avis rendu
par la CNIL sur le décret avec un
délai de conservation des données qui a
été ramenée de 10 à 5 ans et avec un
amendement de la rapporteur qui avait
permis d'apporter un premier niveau de
sécurité sur le fait que les données
n'étaient pas identifiantes et que cet
amendement vient utilement compléter
merci alors Monsieur la tombe
oui merci madame le Président
effectivement en commission des lois
nous avions dès le départ dit que
l'article 33 devait être sérieusement
retravaillé pour le faire rentrer dans
un cadre beaucoup plus sécurisé d'où
effectivement le soutien à ses
amendements et aux sous-amendements de
la rapporteur parce qu'ils viennent
compléter définitivement un ensemble de
dispositions que nous avions adopté en
commission des lois avec la référence la
référence à la sécurité nationale dont
on a eu le débat tout à l'heure avec
avec l'AQPC qui définit chers collègues
très clairement ce que ce qui est
contenu dans dans ce terme et puis là
très clairement ça permet d'éclairer
aussi le l'écriture du décret et de
permettre à ce que l'autorité
administrative soit vraiment contrainte
dans l'écriture du délai et que l'acnil
puisse se faire une validation de du
projet de décret de façon claire puisque
on dit effectivement que les les données
collectées sont rendues anonymes c'est
le rôle de la CNIL elle va pouvoir
expliquer et vérifier comment ça
pourrait être fait mais le fait de le
mettre dans l'article était absolument
nécessaire pour que la CNIL puisse
effectuer son travail de contrôle a
priori puis a postériori nécessaire pour
pouvoir apporter des garanties à nos
concitoyens merci monsieur bernalicis
je voudrais qu'on ait un peu de mémoire
quand même parce que j'ai salué
l'initiative la collègue chassagnol je
voudrais cet amendement mais quand même
avant que il y ait des parlementaires
qui sont par des sujets on vous dit dans
l'étude d'impact non mais vous inquiétez
pas c'est pas identifiant
non mais il y a pas de les données
personnelles rien à voir ce n'est pas le
sujet là on ne va pas prendre les
données personnelles sauf que qui
connaît un peu ces données techniques
c'est que assez facilement on peut
retrouver qui sont les les gens derrière
les adresses IP puis les adresses MAC
d'ailleurs qui souhaitent aussi
conserver sur les données identifiantes
physiques de chaque appareil unique au
monde pour ceux qui savent pas et donc
de savoir où est la personne est c'est
quel dslane elle a à la pas elle est
passée sa position géographique
approximative et que c'est donner là
c'est génial d'ailleurs c'est c'est pour
ça qu'on qu'on fait des publicités qui
peut être aussi un peu plus ciblées par
les gens parce qu'on donnait des données
de cash qui permettent bon bref allez je
veux pas vous saouler avec ça mais du
coup c'est bien c'est bien qu'à la fin
on ne croit pas sur parole ce que nous
raconte le gouvernement dans une étude
d'impact
merci monsieur le député je vais mettre
au voie alors tout d'abord le sous
amendement 1791 de Madame la rapporteur
qui a reçu un avis favorable de monsieur
le ministre qui est pour
qui est contre il est adopté et je vais
mettre au voile les deux amendements
identiques 1626 et 1669 ainsi sous ad
sous amender pardon qui ont reçu un avis
favorable de Madame la rapporteur et
favorable de monsieur le ministre qui
est pour
qui est contre ils sont adoptés je vous
indique sur l'article 33 je suis saisie
d'une demande de scrutin public par le
groupe démocrate que j'annonce dans
l'enceinte de l'Assemblée nationale
madame Thomas le 174 merci madame la
Présidente il s'agit d'un amendement en
lien avec celui défendu dans l'article
32 nous nous interrogeons sur les délais
proposés pour la conservation des
données le choix de la durée de 5 ans
nous apparaît encore une fois arbitraire
et les arguments qui ont été proposés
tout à l'heure ne parviennent pas à nous
convaincre nous considérons qu'il ne
s'agit pas de répondre aux contraintes
de fonctionnement de l'administration ce
qui témoigne de peu de volonté politique
mais que l'administration se conforme au
délai à sa disposition alors donnons les
moyens à l'ancien d'agir avec efficacité
merci Madame la rapporteur Habib
défavorable merci Monsieur le Ministre
défavorable monsieur bernalicis
bon c'est quand même
les délais là on aura jamais des
réponses un peu
tangibles parce que tout à l'heure on
nous a parlé de cas d'espèces monsieur
le ministre lui-même a dit ah ouais mais
cinq ans c'est pas assez le collègue la
tombe j'ai laissé aller un cas d'espèces
remontant à 2017 ce qui fait 6 ans si
mes calculs sont bons si on est bien en
2023 je crois qu'on est bien en 2023
[Musique]
vous êtes sûr que 5 c'est suffisant
monsieur le ministre
non parce que c'est des données certes
non identifiantes puis qui peuvent être
déterminantes et importantes pour
retracer une attaque point de vue de la
sécurité
nationale non moi je trouve deux ans
c'est bien c'est raisonnable y compris
si on voit une attaque et si on voit une
architecture on va pouvoir la mettre sur
papier
l'architecture en tant qu'elles sont
sans pour autant avoir besoin des
données à chaque à chaque étape de de
l'attaque
surtout qu'elles sont pas identifiantes
anonymisées etc donc je vois pas
pourquoi on serait obligé de les garder
autant autant de temps encore une fois
les deux j'ai l'impression vraiment que
ça a été fait sur un coin de Tap c'est
un peu un peu dommage pour des articles
qui peuvent être néanmoins utiles et
d'ailleurs j'ai plutôt un avis plutôt
favorable à cet article 33 et ce serait
parfait franchement nickel si on pouvait
s'arrêter à deux ans de conservation des
données là vraiment on pourrait on
pourrait être presque à 100% d'accord
monsieur le ministre presque
merci je vais mettre moi l'amendement
174 qui a reçu un avis défavorable de la
commission et du gouvernement qui est
pour qui est contre il n'est pas adopté
le 1272 monsieur gordanov merci madame
la Présidente c'est un amendement de
repli par rapport au 1275 que j'ai pas
eu l'occasion de défendre tout à l'heure
mais l'idée c'était de limiter les
données transmises aux données demandées
parce qu'en fait on est sur un volume
qui est quand même extrêmement important
et on va demander toutes les données de
tout le monde même s'il y a pas du tout
de de problèmes de d'attaque etc donc le
1275 c'était pour mon avis le débat en
commission donc je serai bien votre
position là dessus
limitée ou demander aux données demander
le 12100 72 il prévoit de formaliser en
fait la transmission dans un décret
c'est vraiment un amendement de repli
mais
ça fait peser une charge quand même sur
les acteurs concernés et il ressort des
auditions conduites que il faut quand
même formaliser la transmission de
l'information
par des créations merci Madame la
rapporteur avis de la commission merci
madame la Présidente c'était une
précision utile à vie favorable
merci monsieur le ministre
merci Madame la présente Mesdames et
Messieurs le député les députés monsieur
le député alors il faut pas surestimer
le volume de ces données puisqu'il ne
s'agit que de la correspondance entre
les noms de domaine et les adresses IP
une fois anonymisés si l'on peut dire
c'est à dire une fois extraite l'adresse
IP source nonobstant il sera
utile d'adopter cet amendement pour que
la prise du décret puisse être ainsi
éclairé c'est donc un avis favorable
également merci je vais mettre au bout à
l'amendement 1272 qui a reçu un avis
favorable de la commission et du
gouvernement qui est pour
quiconque il est adopté je vais mettre
au voile article 33 qui je vous rappelle
fait l'objet d'un scrutin public que
j'ai annoncé tout à l'heure le scrutin
est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
vos temps 58 exprimé 55 majorité 28 pour
55 contre 0 l'Assemblée nationale a
adopté